hey guys it's Inka and this time I will
only be eating pink colored foods for 24
hours I was scrolling through the
comments and I saw a lot of people
requesting for a pink and so that's why
I decided to go with pink this time so I
know I mentioned doing clear colored
foods and that's still going to happen I
just have something really special
planned for that episode so please look
out for it please be patient coming back
to today as always we will be trying to
find food that is naturally colored pink
I can't really think of too many pink
things the first thing that comes to
mind is cotton candy which is not
exactly the most natural I would do my
best to find some proteins carbs and
some veggies and fruits that are pink so
wish me luck and let's go grocery
shopping again
[Music]
I'm not really sure what to do so I'm
just Kevin James
is a brand-new pink day I don't really
have any like super pink shirts
but I do have this coral pink top that
hopefully will pass for today
so let's get started with breakfast
there's not really that much for this
first meal three things this is a pink
grapefruit so it should be a lot more
Pinker and sweeter than normal
grapefruit and then we have the
strawberry yogurt I really like this
brand because they're usually a lot less
sweet and they focus on using really
simple ingredients and then I'm just
going to cook up some bacon and then we
can plate everything together it's
definitely a lot lighter in color I'm
trying to keep it more pink so it's kind
of really greasy and then over here I'm
realizing the yogurt it's a super light
pink I'm going to pour it out and maybe
add a raspberry to make it a little more
pink and breakfast is done we have the
bacon we have the pink grapefruit here's
the yogurt on camera I feel like it
doesn't look as pink but it's definitely
not your usual red slightly sweeter than
Ruby grapefruits and then for this bacon
is definitely very floppy I don't mind
it honestly still good to finish off we
have this strawberry yogurt I guess now
it's strawberry and raspberry get a big
heaping spoonful this is perfect just to
get my caffeine fix in I was thinking
I'm stopping by one of my favorite cafes
here in New York they're known actually
for this really pretty drink called the
rose petal milk tea really excited to
take your eyes there
so I'm going to finish up cleanup and
then be on my way this is all like
naturally colored Rose syrup
these are little flower petals it is now
lunchtime I'm back here at the tasty
kitchen we have a bunch of assorted
items this is what we have in toto
pancetta and prosciutto both of which
are ready to eat so we have the pink
radish and berry juice and then we have
our spices pink salt and pink
peppercorns two different kinds of
spreads one is this port wine cheese
spread which is I think pink because of
the wine and then we have this it's
called taramosalata
made with lemon juice olive oil and
fresh fish roll it just looks really
interesting and I was really surprised
to find out that there's no pink color
dye in this so I'm excited to test this
out and then in terms of carbs I
enlisted Alvin's help again and that's
high on this side we will find this pink
crepe batter look at how nicely pink it
is so the pink here actually comes from
beets like a beet puree I am excited to
work with this so we can do some sort of
prosciutto radish crepe situations this
mule really is going to be a bit of an
adventure I am going to start making the
crepes first normally with crepes I use
butter but because butter is not pink
i'm hoping this non-stick pan will work
okay I'm not gonna lie it looks like a
giant piece of ham but put once we
played it it will probably look better
this is what it looks like it really
does look like him but that's a pretty
cool-looking creep right there crepes
are done I am now gonna move on to these
pink peppercorns going to try and crush
them a little bit using this it almost
smells floral we'll see how it tastes
we don't even have to cook anything else
because they're all ready to eat my plan
for the prosciutto pancetta and the
radish is to kind of roll them up and
wrap them together I see them do this
out like cocktail parties usually it's
around breadsticks but this could be the
healthier version okay so these are done
just open this port wine cheese I really
don't think I've ever had anything like
this before
wine and cheese usually go together so I
guess this makes sense ooh
not exactly the consistency I was
expecting it's kind of really goopy
smells like fish roe I am just going to
spread these on the crepes now
multiple parts completed so I'm just
gonna throw them all in a plate and we
should be ready for lunch
here is lunch these crepes actually do
look like meat but I promise they're
actually crepes and then we have the
filling in between the prosciutto and
pancetta wrapped around radish with pink
peppercorn and pink salt on top also I
have this drink it's actually mostly
water with one drop of a hibiscus tea
now it's pink time to eat actually gonna
work on one of these first it smells
good actually what am I having that as
an appetizer
they actually paired together pretty
well it's kind of like that sweet savory
combo prosciutto they usually pair it
with melon in this case the daikon is
the sweetness in that pairing and the
peppercorn adds a nice touch this might
just be something that I would snack on
at home even though there's only one
drop of hibiscus in here you can still
taste it I think this is the one with
cheese you definitely get the aged
cheddar kind of like cheese on bread
crepe is good I'm really excited about
this fish roll spread interesting I
think I like the cheese run a little
more the fish hits you right away it
almost like catches me off guard but
it's not like bad I think lunch turned
out to be better than I expected going
to now finish it up and get back to work
around 4:30 right now I think it's a
good time to crack open
this bag of chips these are those crab
shrimp chips that I come should hold me
through until dinner this is actually
really cool because it comes from the
crab and the shrimp this is what it
looks like
it really just tastes like shrimp chips
which I love so I'm here with Inka what
are you eating
pink chips on brand for today please try
these are the chips pink like it oh you
know well I'm back home it's still
pretty early but I think because of the
limited amount of pink foods I've been
able to find I haven't been eating that
much so it's all like digesting very
quickly so I am gonna have an early
dinner today I'm not entirely sure what
I'm doing I don't know I'm missing some
pink vegetables so I might have to have
radish again but let me show you guys
what I have right now this super long
fish sausage made with fish paste as you
can see in the ingredients here pink
peppercorns pink salt then we have the
salmon flakes that I bought that are
more like a coral pink kind of like my
shirt and then we have this really cool
Sakura powder this is how they normally
serve it on rice I haven't had this in a
long time but it's also a type of fish
flake it's like kind of sweet and savory
and it's a very pretty pink color and
then we have these Korean rice cakes I
know they usually use like natural food
coloring to add some color to that rice
cakes I think there's like some kind of
filling in there that's kind of sweet
but I'm missing carbs really not
entirely sure how it's going to go down
but I'll probably pan fry this sausage
and try to pair up the rice cake with
this seasoning we have yeah it's
definitely pink let me try it to cut it
up it smells kind of fishy which makes
sense because this is fish paste
so the sausages are done I'm gonna bring
back the radish that we had earlier so
I'm just gonna cut it and put it on top
of the sausages just gonna repeat these
steps the rest of the ingredients I
don't really need to cook like the
Salmons cooked the rice cakes are cooked
I'm just gonna throw them all together
into the final plate I hope you guys are
ready for this here is our super pink
dish so you can see the sprinkled on
Sakura on the rice cakes the radish the
fish sausage and I put the salmon flakes
in the middle so I think visually it's
pretty appetizing but I don't actually
know the combinations work for drinks I
found this kombucha it's pink because of
the guava puree that's in it let's give
it a try that's a bite the fish sausage
is a very interesting texture it has
less of a bite than what I'm used to
kind of reminds me of those like little
fish sausages that we used to eat as a
kid so now I'm gonna eat the rice cake
with the little Sakura on top actually
with the Sakura powder it's pretty good
there is sort of like a sweet filling
inside I think there's like sugar and
peanuts which is in pink so I'm gonna
try and nibble around it I remain thinks
I'm crazy for trying to eat this without
the filling I'm gonna try to secure a
powder as is actually it's so
interesting the first bite is sweet and
then it becomes savory you can
definitely taste the fish in there but
also a lot of sugar a little bit of
kombucha oh it smells so nice I love
guava and I was really sad this time
that I wasn't able to find pink guava
whew that's so good I'd never even knew
that this was available you know you
guys wanted me to try it eating
something else that wasn't pasta so here
I am I see you playing with my food
really fill it up to the brim with pink
that's so good I guess it makes sense
because this normally goes on rice but
wow that combination was unexpectedly
good I really
I'm going to finish up here gonna finish
off the day with a dessert I'm honestly
so excited about this feed Packaging
aside I think it just comes in like the
perfect portion size strawberry milk
bars it's really just like strawberry
milk but frozen strawberry milk I also
think pink foods was pretty difficult it
was more of a struggle to maintain a
balanced meal somehow we managed to make
it through the day I hope you guys enjoy
it let me know in the comments below
what color you want to see next and see
you guys next time
[Music]